The Tribeca Film Festival is currently underway in New York City.
And while it's best known for premiering independent feature films and documentaries,...
...the festival is also a showcase for virtual reality and interactive entertainment,...
...particularly at its Storyscapes event.
The British newspaper, The Guardian, meanwhile created 6x9.
A project that takes you inside solitary confinement.
Once you put on the glasses,...
...you're in a prison cell for nearly ten minutes...
...while interview subjects who've gone through solitary confinement...
...tell you what it's actually like.
The voices that you hear are people who were previously incarcerated.
So, there are six men, one woman who were in solitary confinement in California or in New York.
And two psychologists who have studied the impact on the brain...
...when you are in solitary confinement.